my husband Dominic he's an amazing
husband he's a great guy very loving
very caring
but when fall comes around it all
suddenly changes when football season
starts my husband is obsessed with
football on Sundays he barely talks to
me inside I don't even exist babe we
have talked about this ever since we
started dating Sundays aren't made for
relationships they're made for football
it's not just on Sundays Mondays
Thursday or Saturdays it's nonstop
talking on the phone about the bug King
please get up she makes me feel like I'm
the only guy in the world that's into
football but it's like every one of my
friends are exactly the same way I love
my husband but honestly I can't take it
anymore I feel like I just disappear
[Music]
[Applause]
you're not really that bad right well oh
you hesitated okay it's been a passion
since a kid I've always been into
football grew up watching football with
my father and just something that's just
in bed and so it's just the problem
though Suchi is more than watching
football right it's more than just
watching a football game he's really
into fantasy football
so he'll wake up like
[Applause]
I'll wake up 5:00 in the morning he'll
check the status of his players he'll
call his cousin's his brother so they're
all talking on the phone they're in the
group text message and I basically don't
get any attention or communication Suchi
would be become a fan well no I mean I I
don't want her to necessarily become a
fan I just kind of kind of want Sunday's
to my you know to myself to watch
football my favorite part was and you
were like relationships aren't supposed
to happen on like somebody needs to tell
God have you tried watching games with
Dominic yes I have I checked some
YouTube videos I went on Google and I
get into it too I you know I did try
watching some games with him but I just
I couldn't get into it Kelly yeah I find
it kind of I find it kind of boring me
too I think pressive what they do it's
just some people don't like to chill
watching and I'm saying that's not my
vibe That's not me either but so ladies
any of your guys any of your guys like
this they're not like my fiance he
played football and did track I'm like
very very athletic and he loves football
his whole family loves football so what
I do is when he's like I am non-existent
when games are on I just go sit in the
tub and prune and just have a great time
have some wine go book a massage I'm
like oh you want to keep that day for
you I will do a me day I'll be great you
know my gosh you got a balance I have no
idea but how long does it last five and
a half five and a half okay oh two
months and wait it out that fire yeah
how is this impacted jealous
relationships uchi um basically our
quality time especially when I come home
from a long day at work I want to be
able to talk to him about it he's my
best friend so I I I just love spending
time with him about everything but I
know at times he pretends like he's
listening it just I mean you think you
give up like one day there's like it's
not just Thursday or just money it says
it's all the days I feel like what
fantasy I mean you're constantly
checking update so fantasy is pretty
much everyday Sunday's the games are on
all day of course you have Monday Night
Football and Thursday you should be a
commentator okay so would you mind I
make if maybe like I helped her find
something to do on Sundays no I'm
totally open to it yeah
thing I've always had an interest for
dance especially hip hop yeah I wouldn't
mind taking some nights uchi some hip
hop I just pictured you in a club it was
well I've got someone here who can teach
you all about dancing you know him from
his time on Dancing with the Stars I'm
so excited about this please welcome
Maksim Chmerkovskiy
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay I love that you brought my wardrobe
that's my wardrobe that's so weird that
you have to know really what is that is
that is that some yeah so so first of
all I have to say that we thank you for
having me we have absolutely nothing to
do I've never met him before we just go
you don't saying do I go both halves
like this right here this believe it or
not this is a dress in my wife's closet
just for those I want to be your wife I
think that we're gonna talk about what
I'm doing here yeah so I figured I think
is the right thing to you like to offer
alternatives you know I'm saying like I
also love football Dominic but I also
love the fact that you know I mean I
can't deny Peter for example her time on
Sundays right so we you know we figure
things out I don't play fantasy because
it takes up a lot of time what I want to
offer what I want to offer suchi is that
you know during the time on Sundays when
you feel a little kind of like what
would wide you I would like to you know
be your Sundays partner if you know what
I'm saying and
[Applause]
right I have a plan because I feel like
you know I feel like this is the hobby
that you were looking forward to first
of all this dance this dress is gonna be
hopefully on you by the time we're done
because we're gonna prepare an amazing
sexy hot dance routine that you're gonna
dance on this show we're gonna come up
with something hot and sexy obviously
you know fitting for this whatever the
thing this this thing I have a group of
amazing to look at and learn from
dancers that are gonna be working with
you the performance here on this show is
not gonna be our last performance it's
gonna be our kind of like a attack run
if you will for the big grand
performance which is that you're not
going to dance at one of the Super Bowl
parties in Miami this coming Super Bowl
weekend I'm your plus one so he can't
come
[Music]
[Applause]
irony the ideas that maybe dominica you
know one saying like I'm gonna join this
this is this is this this has to be us
no I join you I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this